imaginez
imaginez que vous receviez une lettre à
votre naissance une lettre qui vous aide
à grandir et à avancer dans la vie
j'aurais aimé recevoir cette lettre
alors je l'ai écrit je l'ai écrit à
Charlie qui vient de naître qui m'est
très cher et j'ai mis mes connaissances
de chercheuse mes expériences de vie
et c'est une lettre qui parle de cercle
et de liberté
je vais la partager avec vous ce soir
alors cherche Charlie cher tous faire
toutes la vie c'est bizarre on a rien
demandé
elle est là tout simplement et nous on
débarque dans un monde tellement étrange
tellement complexe qu'on ne comprend pas
alors nous n'avons de cesse que de
construire des cercles de rentrer dans
des cercles
alors Charlie au début c'est les bras de
ton papa et de ta maman qui t'encercle
après c'est le cercle la famille le
cercle des copains le cercle des
collègues
et puis ça va être des cercles
institutionnels le Cercle des Officiers
un cercle littéraire tu vas rêver devant
des cercles imaginaires le cercle des
poètes disparu ou des cercles mythiques
le cercle polaire
jusque là tout est normal il est
tellement agréable de comprendre le
monde d'être avec des gens qui nous
aiment qui nous respectent et qui nous
donne une place dans la société
puis comme on est dans un monde digital
sans t'en rendre compte les algorithmes
vont filtrer tes données et te faire
entrer dans les cercles des bulles et te
faire rejoindre des gens qui pensent
comme toi qui vivent comme toi et
surtout qui consomment comme toi
et là bien au chaud dans ta bulle
tu vas commencer à te rendre compte
qu'il y a un dedans et un dehors qu'il y
a nous et les autres alors nous c'est la
bande de potes la promotion de diplômée
le club de tennis le quartier
et les autres c'est ceux qui ne pensent
pas comme toi qui n'ont pas la même
orientation sexuelle pas la même couleur
de peau qui ne prie pas le même dieu que
Toi
et ces autres cette extérieur et bien
il t'intrigue qui te font peur
t'inquiète il te fascine et là le cercle
protecteur
devient peut-être le cercle qui enferme
et qui empêche d'aller vers d'autres
horizons et vers son propre projet
Ionesco a écrit prenez un cercle
caressez-le il deviendra vicieux alors
Charlie il y a quatre grands cercles
vicieux
le premier c'est le cercle de la
bienveillance avec cette petite phrase
c'est pour ton bien c'est pour ton bien
pour son bien que des parents vont
dissuader une fille d'aller vers des
études qu'il jugent trop ambitieuses
trop masculine c'est pour son bien que
des amis vont empêcher l'un des leurs de
changer de projet professionnel
c'est pour leur bien qu'une entreprise
va par bienveillance proposer des
trajets professionnels tout tracés
le cercle bienveillant peut être un
cercle qui enferme le son concept
vicieux c'est la cage de verre alors
dans la cage de verre tout est possible
dans la réalité toutes les études le
montrent il est très difficile pour une
femme de devenir PDG d’entreprise du CAC
très difficile pour un senior de plus de
55 ans de retrouver un travail très
difficile pour un obèse d'avoir une
promotion managériale très compliquée
pour un jeune des banlieues de faire des
études supérieures la cage de verre elle
est faite de parois invisibles mais
extrêmement solide car ces parois elles
sont faites de croyances profondes les
croyances profondes c'est des choses qui
nous ont envahi petit à petit sans qu'on
s'en rende compte ce sont des intensées
mais ce sont aussi des verrou mentaux et
il est très difficile de se débarrasser
des croyances profondes car il est
beaucoup plus difficile de désapprendre
ce qu'on n'a pas appris que ce qu'on a
appris
il est facile de désapprendre d'oublier
une équation de maths un théorème de
physique une règle de grammaire facile
mais dès à prendre des choses qu'on n'a
pas apprises qui sont des impensés mais
c'est très compliqué alors une
illustration
vous n'avez jamais appris formellement
que la France était au centre du monde
et pourtant tous les jours tous les
jours pendant votre scolarité vous avez
eu ce planisphère à côté du tableau à
l'école
et voilà vous pensez vous bien pensez
que la France est au centre du monde les
croyances profondes le problème aussi
c'est qu'elles font le lit des préjugés
et préjugés
avant
sans prendre le temps
sans faire l'effort de connaître les
personnes on les catégorie on les met
dans des cercles et c'est comme ça que
les Français sont râleurs les femmes ne
savent pas commander ce qu'on dit
lunettes sont des intellectuels ce qu'on
est tatouages sont des marginaux
les jeunes ne veulent rien faire les
vieux sont résistants changements tout
le monde le sait des impensés des verrou
mentaux le troisième cercle vicieux
c'est l'effet golem c'est l'affreux et
fait golem il est fait de quoi il est
fait de petites phrases assassines qui
vous enferme dans un rôle qui vous
assigne une personnalité des petites
phrases qui vous étouffent à bas bruit
tu es méchant tu es paresseux tu ne sais
rien faire qu'est-ce qu'il est nul mais
on peut rien attendre de toi ce téfé
golem est bien nous verrouille tous nos
possibles nous font penser qu'on ne peut
pas aller vers nos projets il y a une
illustration très forte de cet effet
golem c'est le test des poupées blanches
et des poupées noires des psychologues
montrent à des petits enfants de 4-5 ans
afro-américains une poupée blanche et
une poupée noire et il leur demande
quelle est la poupée qui te ressemble et
bien c'est la poupée noire mais après il
demande quelle est la poupée la plus
belle la plus gentille la plus
intelligente et bien c'est la poupée
blanche et pourquoi parce qu'elle est
blonde aux yeux bleus
ses enfants tout petits ont déjà intégré
tous les interdits liés à leur couleur
de peau et le dernier cercle vicieux le
quatrième et bien c'est la roue de
hamster
quand plus rien ne va quand on perd le
sens quand tout est catastrophe est bien
par un effet de rétrécissement cognitif
on entre dans la roue de hamster ça veut
dire qu'on fait toujours plus du même
les réunions ne fonctionnent pas on fait
plus de réunions les indicateurs ne vont
pas on fait plus d'indicateurs
les disputes ne mènent à rien plus de
disputes les punitions rien mais on fait
plus de punition
c'est la roue de hamster et dans la roue
de hamster on perd le sens
et on s'épuise littéralement
alors Charlie si je t'écris si je vous
écris à tous c'est pour vous dire bien
sûr qu'il y a ces quatre cercles vicieux
mais il y a aussi la possibilité d'en
sortir et pour cela il y a trois clés
magiques la première c'est de pivoter et
de regarder les situations les personnes
autrement
c'est décrocher le planisphère et
regardez le monde
upside down comme disent les Australiens
par en dessous
c'est le même monde c'est la même
planète on la voit pas du tout de la
même façon et plus la France il y a un
bel océan bleu dans lequel on peut
plonger la deuxième clé magique c'est le
pourquoi il faut avoir le courage de se
poser la question qui tue pourquoi
je pense comme ça pourquoi je fais ça
pourquoi je décide ça
et si la réponse est parce que j'ai
toujours fait comme ça
parce que j'ai toujours pensé comme ça
parce qu'on m'a dit de faire comme ça et
bien c'est la sclérose annoncée
donc comme une hygiène mentale tous les
jours Charlie tous les jours cher tout
ce qu'il faudrait se dire pourquoi
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas moi et si et si et s'ouvrir
des possibles
et la troisième clé magique la plus
importante c'est la confiance la
confiance des autres
ce sont des parents qui croient dans le
projet de leur fille de devenir
ingénieur
c'est un professeur qui va dire à son
étudiant tu peux réussir ce concours
c'est une grande mère qui va croire dans
le talent de son petit-fils pour être
danseur
c'est un inconnu qui va dire bravo tu
l'as fait dans un défi sportif qui
paraissait insurmontable et cette
confiance des autres et bien elle donne
confiance en soi cette confiance en soi
elle donne confiance en l'avenir la
confiance en l'avenir elle donne
confiance dans les autres et là on entre
dans un cercle qui est vertueux le
cercle de la confiance c'est très
important il y a plein de belles
personnes qui ont réussi à briser ses
cercles qui auraient pu les enfermer
alors j'ai pensé à Serena Williams la
grande championne de tennis qui a été au
sommet dans un sport
réservé aux Blancs riches j'ai pensé à
du carolings jeune maman célibataire des
argentés qui est devenu l'écrivain la
plus connue au monde avec la saga Harry
Potter mais aussi à Steve Jobs le
mythique créateur d'Apple qui avait la
fêlure d'un enfant adopté ou bien Steven
Hawking le théoricien de la physique de
l'univers alors qu'il était entièrement
paralysé alors ils ont brisé les cercles
et les enfermés mais il ne s'agit pas
Charlie il ne s'agit pas pour vous
d'être le plus grand écrivain le plus
grand théoricien le plus grand
entrepreneur il s'agit d'être soit soit
tout simplement
avec ses projets ses talents ces
difficultés
et là on se dit et on s'entend dire tu
es libre de tu es libre de changer de
d'étude de changer de ville de changer
de carrière de changer de nom de changer
de sexe c'est tellement précieux d'être
libre
et à ce moment c'est circuler il y a
rien à voir il y a plus de gens bizarres
il y a plus de gens non conformes il y a
plus l'appareesseuse le méchant le
inutile il n'y a que des belles
personnes qui vont vers leur destin
et il y a le grand poète néchard qui te
murmure à l'oreille Charlie qui vous
murmurera l'oreille
impose ta chance
serre ton bonheur
et va vers ton risque à te regarder il
s'habitueront merci
[Applaudissements]